you often hear from people who don't
live in New York City and haven't lived
in New York City that they couldn't live
in New York City because they're not
that kind of person that's always struck
me as a strange and somewhat
incomprehensible thing to say being
myself in New York City and meeting
everyday people who because they live
here must be that kind of person it's
strange because taking together all of
them the web of their qualities and
desires and flaws I can't quite envision
the types who are left out the thing is
I don't trust them I don't trust that
they haven't confused
an idea of New York City for the real
thing and for that matter I don't trust
that they haven't confused an idea of
themselves for the real New York it's
conventionally thought is big and loud
and fast and drunk and it is those
states
poor man Scotch shared the troops
so cool
but New York can be as small as it is
big as quiet and slow as it is loud and
fast the city when viewed from within is
really a collection of peculiar
neighborhoods which is to say a
collection of charm this is my friend
now this is Jerry each has their own
secrets each has their own weird
identities and each has their own set of
random accumulated rules like when the
horses come out at 2:00 a.m. on Essex in
the Lower East Side or when the wealthy
folk go out to get their brunch on
Sunday mornings in the Upper West or how
we all just assumed that Street meat is
perfectly safe because it tastes so
[ __ ] good mustard please copious
amounts of mustard always haggle always
these neighborhoods cohere not around a
quality common to all but by a kind of
VidCon Stinney and family resemblance by
a series of overlapping similarities
like the series of overlapping character
traits that give to its 8.2 million
inhabitants a kindred bond and a bond
that holds fast in tragedy and pain for
me what makes being in New York City
extraordinary is the feeling of standing
on the knife's edge of history what it
must have felt like to be at Rome during
the Caesars or at London in the height
of empire it's as if you're surfing the
wave of time you can see what's coming
and you can see every expression of
humanity amplified and multiplied made
stranger and more tolerant New York
overwhelms you into a kind of unceasing
aww and you can feel everything on every
corner all the time there are a lot of
hedonist in New York City and a lot of
good people but it may be the best place
in the universe anyway it's the best
place in the universe to get a drink at
4:00 in the morning yep yep coming